i'm joined now by the shadow leader of
the house of commons thank them debonair
thanks for being with us so what do you
make of these photos
well i'm afraid that you know what i
make of them is there's nothing compared
to the people who i've spoken to over
the last few months who went through
terrible terrible times in 2020 people
who were perhaps working in the nhs or
in care homes who put their health at
risk on a daily basis to care for others
people who lost loved ones and couldn't
be with them to say goodbye people who
couldn't be at funerals or at the birth
of their child
and what they will feel today is what
counts they will see a prime minister
who broke the rules after having made
the rules they will see a prime minister
who is clearly at a party during
lockdown when they were making great
sacrifices
and i think they will also feel that
they've been really let down by someone
who was clearly presiding over an
establishment number 10 downing street
at which parting was taking place on a
massive scale it is the most fined
address in the uk i really think it's
time he did the decent thing but uh the
police have seen these photos and he has
not been fined
um for this occasion or event um so the
police have made their decision
well quite
i would say however that for anyone
who's been through the experiences that
i've mentioned would look at those and
say even if there isn't a case that the
police have found to answer there is
certainly a moral case in which it's
obvious that the prime minister was was
doing was having a good time drinking
wine with his mates at work while they
were doing all of the things that we
were asked to do to stay at home to not
visit lonely relatives
not go into hospital to see the birth
their child all of those things that
people sacrificed and that's what they
will see but if the police have said
that
he wasn't breaking the law because i
assume if he was breaking the law they'd
have issued a
a fixed penalty notice um
how can you say that he is
well i didn't say that what i said was i
think it's hard for people to watch i
think it's very hard for people who've
made those sacrifices but also he has
already been found to break the law he
broke the law and was issued with a
fixed penalty notice and fell to resign
then i think the added question now is
did he lie intentionally or
unintentionally to the house of commons
which is a very serious matter on the
13th of december
on the 8th of december last year he said
to my colleague catherine west that
there had been no such parties and
clearly he knew they had because he was
there at one that's counts as well and
it matters because it really matters
what sort of a tone the prime minister
sets and if he sets it home which says
he can say what he likes to the house of
commons no matter what that's really
really bad right and there is an
investigation to that just on this
photograph last point uh or last
question rather the i mean the cabinet
office has them or has seen them sue
gray has seen them uh she has the
context no doubt uh
isn't it just worth waiting for what she
says about these photographs
well really that sugai report does need
to be published as soon as possible i
don't know what the hold up is but
whatever it is they need to get a move
on and i appreciate that sugro has been
a diligent civil servant working very
hard but there's now the question of
whether or not downing street number 10
summoned her to a meeting to have a
discussion which we don't know the
details of as yet i urge the government
to publish the sue grey report as soon
as possible and in full so that we can
all see the evidence that she's had
before her okay well we're told it's
coming in the next few days so fangam
debonair thank you very much indeed
thank you